So if you were planning to introduce yourself, I'll go ahead.
All right, Steve Lawson.
We're here in a room at the Valley Library.
It's the 14th day of November 2011.
Okay, so today we will principally be talking about the Institute at OAC, but there's a couple of things I wanted to touch on.
So the past chronology of our talks that we didn't actually get to.
And the first is an important question.
I think that's if you can just sort of trace how you advanced into the ranks of executive officer,
then she could be actually also a professor at OAC.
Sure, that was quite a surprise.
I think in our last conversation, I'd outline some of the financial problems that the Institute had been chronically experiencing.
These got way back to the 1970s, where staff was asked to take pay cuts and the contribution to the retirement plan was decreased periodically for a set period of time.
So employees in the Institute were no strangers to financial hardship.
Salaries were not very competitive, fairly low, probably when compared salaries to roughly equivalent positions in academia or in the private sector in that time.
But I think people had a great passion for the Linus-Plying Institute, which is why I worked there, certainly, because I really felt strongly about the mission and I really liked Linus-Plying.
The more I found out about him, the more I liked him, and I was very pleased and kind of honored to be part of the Linus-Plying Institute of Science and Medicine.
And as my skills developed in science, and I started to get involved in more and more projects, I found it very challenging and lots of fun.
And I think I demonstrated some aptitude, or I don't think I would have been asked by Paul and others to participate at the level I was asked.
Then in the mid-1980s, Emil Zucicondo, who succeeded Art Robinson as President Director of the Institute, was getting very interested in using a relatively new technique called Two-Dimensional Polyacrylamide Gel Electrophoresis to profile proteins that might demonstrate the importance of the development of the Linus-Plying Institute of Science and Medicine.
That might distinguish tumor cells from primary tissue, from metastatic tumor tissue.
And we set up a laboratory together and started on a fairly productive collaboration.
And as a result of that, I became co-director of the lab for research and gene regulation, and reported directly to Emil Zucicondo.
And Emil and I got along very, very well. I really respected him.
An extraordinarily intelligent person. I can see why his collaboration with Paul and was so successful in the early 1960s.
And as the institute moved to the point of inflection of the decades, Emil's tenure was coming to an end.
And as I mentioned last time, Emil and Rickiick's departed from the institute because I think Emil was unwilling to make some of the changes that the board felt were necessary to align income with outgoing.
So the institute had expanded pretty dramatically under Emil's direction and had become kind of a broad molecular biological biomedical research organization.
So it had some areas of orthomolecular medicine, but it also had areas that were really not germane to orthomolecular medicine that were of interest to Emil specifically and to others, of course, who were carrying out the specific research project at the institute.
So when Emil left, and Linus Pong, of course, had become sick and was not interested in carrying out many administrative responsibilities.
Linus Pong Jr. stepped in to fill an obvious void there. And that began kind of my long association with Linus Pong Jr.
I got to know him very well, and I think we worked together very well as well. I took care of the day-to-day management of the institute and Linus Pong Jr.
As a result of his experience in wisdom provided some direction to me as well.
I think I mentioned last time that when the institute was going through this reorganization, a fate of different research projects and researchers within the organization was really up in the air.
And people weren't sure whether they would be asked to remain with the institute or whether they would be laid off.
So researchers whose work was pretty carefully aligned with the newly refocused orthomolecular medical mission felt fairly confident about remaining with the institute.
And others were really anxious, of course.
At some point there was a board meeting, and there were board meetings more often during this period. Board meetings had been relatively rare during my tenure at the institute.
I was never sure exactly when a board meeting was being held. I think that they were held probably as often as required by law, but not very often.
But during this period of change in turmoil board meetings were quite regular. And I remember being, of course, I was unsure about my fate within the institute as well.
Because the work I was doing was really not related specifically to orthomolecular medicine. So I was concerned that I might be losing my job.
And I was aware of a meal's imminent departure. So I obviously was concerned about my future then too.
And it came as a great surprise during a board meeting when I was summoned to the To Linus Plan's office where the board was meeting by Dorothy Monroe.
And I had no idea why they wanted to talk to me or what I could offer to the board, but nevertheless I went down it, met with the board.
And at that time they introduced some changes that they had been thinking about, and they asked me for my opinion of these changes.
And on the board and the office there, somebody had written out kind of an organizational chart for the institute.
And I looked at it and made a few comments and generally thought that I opined that I thought it was a good opinion.
I mean it was a good idea that they had decided to really make clear the responsibilities within the institute because it was something that was of great concern to people.
The institute had operated, managed early as a bit of a black box and decisions were not always clear and the rationale for decisions were not always obvious.
And I think that's true in any organization, but in a small organization it can be a can cause a lot of problems.
So during the board meeting they asked me also I believe if I was interested in participating in the reorganized institute.
And without giving it much thought at the time I said yes, I was a bit surprised and also I think a bit flattered by this invitation to assume more responsibility within the institute.
And I thought it was likely to be quite a challenge. At that time I had no idea just how dramatic a challenge it would be, but I knew that it would be stimulating.
And like I said earlier, I like to solve problems and I saw quite a few problems and I thought that I might be helpful in tackling them.
So your panel changed at some point though from the executive office of the chief executive?
Right. It went through metamorphosis. Initially Linus Pauling had asked me to be, I think the title was assistant to the president when he assumed very temporarily the role of president.
And I took that job seriously. I didn't really know what it entailed, but I took it seriously.
And I started thinking about things that needed to be acted upon at the institute.
And I think I produced a list of some things that needed to be done and my rationale for doing them and gave that to Linus Pauling.
And he left for a few months to go down to Big Sur. So there was really a bit of a vacuum.
And I think Linus Pauling Jr. recognized that his father at that time recognized that his father really had no interest in managing the institute.
And I was left without much direction at that point. I'd been given a new title, but I didn't really have a firm grasp of what I was expected to do.
And I didn't really feel that I had the authority to do what I thought was in the best interest in the institute because I was not the chief administrator of the institute.
So my job title changed when the board reorganized the institute and asked me to become involved in management from that to executive officer.
And I think executive officer has come an old terminology from the military. And maybe after a year or so as executive officer, I was named chief executive officer.
I think it was just the title change. I think it was just recognizing the actual duties that I was performing at the institute.
Because Linus Pauling Jr. of course was still living in Hawaii. And he would come to the institute periodically, sometimes as often as once a month for a day or two.
Excuse me, but I was handling all the day-to-day administrative tasks at the institute. And also we had litigation at that time and trying to, we were trying to chart a course for the future.
And all those things I was acting on on a daily basis and thinking about and discussing with my colleagues at the institute and elsewhere.
I believe he became chairman of the board of trustees and Linus Pauling Sr. at some point became director of research.
Which was a little odd because technically Linus Pauling on the board was responsible. I reported to the board, so I reported to Linus Pauling. But as director of research he also technically reported to me as chief executive officer.
So it was kind of an odd situation but it didn't interfere with our relationship or any of our activities because I don't think we let titles get in the way.
Another thing that we touched on in our last meeting that I wanted to follow up on real quick here was the Linus Pauling Foundation.
All right. I mentioned that in the context of something that the CSR actually involved in. I wonder what became of that?
Right. As I mentioned, some of the CSR's activities were unknown to employees of the institute. We became vaguely aware at some point that other organizations with kind of a parallel mission to the institute were being set up by Pauling and Raff.
And that caused a little consternation because we weren't sure if, and I wasn't in management at that time, but we, the employees at the institute weren't sure if these other organizations were going to be competitive with the institute.
Were they going to compete for funds for the same donors for instance or the same organizations.
And at some point it became clear to me that it really wasn't strictly competitive but I didn't really see the rationale for having independent organizations to carry out this work.
So I believe that Raff and Pauling set up the Linus Pauling and Raff Foundation because they were anxious to sort of get around the management of the institute and raise money and carry out clinical trials in vitamin C and heart disease specifically after a sclerosis.
And do more investigative work, maybe mechanistic work on lysine, proline, vitamin C and lipoprotein A, which was the main focus of Pauling's research interests at that time in North and Malachia Medicine.
But Raff had, as he and Pauling were starting to grow apart because Pauling I think was expressing some decrease in confidence in Raff's behavior.
And the behavior and abilities Pauling decided to wrap up the Linus Pauling heart foundation.
And I believe this was probably after Raff had left the institute but here was this organization that had an independent life, had headquarters and a small office building in California Avenue just a few blocks from the institute and Raff had apparently hired several people to do work there.
So they were on the payroll and some of the activities of the foundation apparently were surprised Pauling because when he was informed about these things he was not pleased about some of the activities the foundation was undertaken.
So he asked me if I would wind up the Linus Pauling heart foundation and transfer the assets to the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine to carry out work and heart disease.
So I told him I'd be happy to do that and said about legally dissolving the Linus Pauling heart foundation and taking the physical assets back to the 440 page mail road facility and also transferring the financial assets to a restricted account at the Linus Pauling.
Institute of Science and Medicine.
Okay so the last, at the end of our interview last time we were at the point Pauling died in 1994.
He received a couple of pieces of substantial gifts that had kept the institute more or less alive.
You also know you need to leave power for the benefit of the commission.
And in 1996 the institute moved to OSU some interested in knowing how that process carried out.
Let me back up briefly in 1994.
It was a very pivotal year in many respects not just because of Pauling's death but it was also the year that we celebrated the 20th anniversary of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
And we started early, let's see I think it must have been late spring or early summer.
Maybe it was late spring. Let me see now I'm confused about the year was it 1993 or 1994.
Perhaps it was 1993 when we celebrated the 20th anniversary that would have been the appropriate year at Ringstorf House in Mountain View, California.
And that was an opportunity for Pauling to see some of his old friends and colleagues.
We invited quite a few of his colleagues from academic institutions and local donors and friends of the institute.
Of course the staff, faculty and staff of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine and their guests.
So it was a really terrific event at a beautiful renovated Victorian house that was on the mud flats in Mountain View.
Special collections came representatives of special collections here at OSU.
Came down with some of Pauling's medals and awards that he'd already given to the university.
So they were on display and we had postures, scientific postures.
It was really a great time for Pauling to meet and greet perhaps for the last time some of his associates.
And then in 1994 also to celebrate the 20th anniversary of the Linus Plains Institute of Science and Medicine.
We decided to convene a large scientific conference.
In the institute had historically convened a number of conferences.
One was to honor Bjorn Nordinstrom from the Carolinsky Institute.
Pauling became quite interested in his bioelectric theory of cancer therapy, which was quite interesting.
So there was a symposium to honor him.
And then some years earlier there had been another symposium called Nutrition Health and Peace convened by the institute with presentations by a whole raft of people doing work in orthomolecular medicine, molecular biology and chemistry.
Again a little bit to honor Linus Pauling's work in orthomolecular medicine science and peace.
And of course there had been birthday parties for Linus Pauling and the Linus Pauling and Warpher humanitarianism.
So there had been a lot of events throughout the history of the Linus Plains Institute.
Some were the fundraiser and focus and some were the scientific focus.
But of course Linus Pauling was always at the midst of these occasions.
So we decided that an appropriate 20th anniversary event would be a conference.
The scientific conference organized around the theme of orthomolecular medicine.
And Linus Pauling was pleased to hear about this.
And we decided to call it the therapeutic potential of biological antioxidants.
And we had a scientific committee and organizing committee set up at the institute that reviewed poster abstracts and invited people to speak at the conference.
I remember going into Pauling's office to ask him what he thought of our provisional title,
the therapeutic potential of biological antioxidants.
And in his very characteristic way, Lin back in his chair and closed his eyes and thought for a minute.
And without even opening his eyes, he said to me, well, I think it's fine.
But we shouldn't forget that molecules like vitamin C serve many functions in the body.
They're not strictly committed to being only antioxidants.
They also have very other important properties.
And we shouldn't forget that. And I agreed with him completely.
But he gave his blessing to our provisional title for the conference.
So that he also agreed to be the keynote speaker at the conference.
And this was scheduled for the fall of 1994, September.
And people like Bruce Ames and Balthes Frye and Rett Traiber, Lester Packer, Enrique Cadenas.
A lot of people in the free radical field were there.
And I hadn't met some of these people before.
I had met Bruce Ames and Balthes Frye as early as 1989 when they came to the Institute to give a seminar on vitamin C.
Because Ames had published with Frye a paper in PNAS that year showing that a score bay is the outstanding antioxidant in human blood.
And a pecking order at number one in Pauline, of course, was very excited by that paper.
And they were invited to come to the seminar and during the day of the earthquake, actually, as it turned out.
So there were a lot of interesting people invited to speak at our conference.
And then, of course, Pauline died at the end of August.
So I asked Henry Talbe, who was one of Pauline's friends, and had done work in free radical chemistry as well.
If he would step in as a substitute for Linus Pauline and give the keynote address at our conference.
He was happy to do so. That was very gracious of him to consent to do that at the last minute.
Because he was very active at Stanford. And I'm sure there were many demands on his time.
And I thought it was terrific that he really rose to the occasion and agreed to give that talk, which went very well.
I drove him up to Timuron, picked him up at Stanford and drove him to Timuron that day to give the talk.
And he did a not standing job, really, really thrilled to group there.
So after Pauline had died, of course, and before his death, we were engaged in analyzing options for the future of the institute.
And I discussed some ideas with some of the people that had attended the therapeutic potential biological antioxidants in September.
And then was approached in 1993-1994. I was also working with a fellow named Bill Kemp, who was introducing me to people in different universities around the country.
And we had been talking, as I mentioned last time, with people all over the place.
Bill had arranged for me to meet the governor of Oklahoma. At the Jonathan Club in Los Angeles.
Because the governor of Oklahoma was on a trip, as many governors do, to try to get businesses to relocate, or move some of their operations to the state of Oklahoma.
Because that's the economic engine that drives the state.
So I met with the governor at the Jonathan Club. It was kind of a funny meeting.
It was in a really luxurious room at the Jonathan Club. And the governor was there with his chief of staff, and maybe a dozen or 14 other people.
They were all paying rapt attention to everything that he said and did. They were all aligned on one side of a long, long conference table.
And it was me on the other side of the conference table. I had no people. I had no retinue. I had no advisors. Just me.
And I had a great conversation with him. And he invited me and Linus Pongini to go to Oklahoma City to make a presentation to the president of the university, the president of the foundation there.
Which operates in a similar way to the Oregon State University Foundation here with their relationship to the local university, or the state school, I should say.
But anyway, getting back to more specifically your question.
Other people came and made presentations to our board about their ideas for relocation.
And one of the people who came was John Byrne, who brought with him, I believe he brought with him, Dick Scanlan, who was dean of research at that time.
And Oregon State University in many ways, I mean, just superficially seemed to be a good fit because Linus Pongini was his alma mater.
He had already agreed to give his and his wife's personal professional memorabilia to Oregon State University to be housed in a new special collections, forms sort of the nucleus of special collections.
So it seemed like a good fit, but we weren't really sure about the specifically how the institute would work into the program here.
So John Byrne and Dick Scanlan talked about the centers and institutes that were already extant at Oregon State University and how they were organized and how they reported to and how they were staffed and so forth.
And they talked a bit about the nutrition department and the work that was going on there, exercise and sports physiology and medicine, pharmacy, biochemistry and bio physics, environmental and molecular toxicology.
So the growing programs that seemed to have some relevance to the institute's mission.
And that led to, of course, many discussions and meetings between staff at Oregon State University and our staff at the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine, including hosting a meeting between a committee that John Byrne had put together to seriously analyze this process.
And analyze this prospect of the institute relocating to Oregon State University to find out whether it was really a good thing to do or not.
John Leong, George Bailey, a number of other people were on that committee.
And they came down to Palo Alto and I hosted them for a day and talked about the mission of the institute and how we had been funded historically.
We talked a lot about the scientific work, a lot about the fundraising work. They weren't really familiar with the term orthomolecular.
So we spent quite a lot of time thinking about that and discussing it.
And I think they came to realize that some of the work that Dave themselves were doing could be considered orthomolecular, but they hadn't really applied that term to their own work.
I think as a result of those many meetings, it became clear that there was a good fit between the Linus Pong Institute and Oregon State University, although it wasn't tenable to bring the whole institute with all its employees up to Corvallis because there was just too many people.
I can't remember what the specific number of employees was at that time, but back before the reorganization, there were maybe 70, 75 people at the institute.
And then after the reorganization, that was dropped down to maybe 50 or so.
And of course, with the institute moving to Oregon State University, a lot of the administrator functions that we had to assume ourselves in Palo Alto, we would no longer have to assume.
So we had no need for a controller or bookkeeper or we still had need for a fundraiser, but of course the fundraising activities were going to be taken over by the OSU Foundation.
So we didn't really need to have a fundraising staff to come with us to Oregon State University.
So we had broad and deep discussions about all those issues.
And the researchers at the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine, who the Dean of Research and the AdHoc Committee formed by John Bern believed had the best chance of succeeding here at Oregon State University,
we were asked to come up and meet the faculty and staff that they might interact with here on campus in the different departments.
So there were a number of visits back and forth between OSU and LPISM.
And as a result of that, Dick Scanlon was pretty frank with me about who might really succeed at Oregon State University and what might be the most important part of the Linus Pong Institute to bring up to Oregon State University.
And that led to the decision to bring a relatively small nucleus of people about half a dozen to Oregon State University.
Now there were some people that I think could have made the transition had they wanted to, but they had, for instance, there was one fellow doing work that was supported by Department of Energy Grant at the Institute in Palo Alto.
And his wife was a physician and they had a comfortable life in the Bay Area and they really didn't want to leave.
And there were other people who also were approaching retirement age and decided that it might just be best to retire rather than move to Oregon.
So there were a lot of factors that came into play in determining who actually moved to Corvallis.
But at the time we had a very, and I mentioned this the last time, a really good contractual relationship with Unilever and Elizabeth Arden that was continuing.
So the people involved with that particular project were given offered jobs at Oregon State University and a number of other people were as well.
So how many people did you think you'd say that was about half a dozen?
I think they were about half a dozen. Six or seven people total.
It was Conor McEvally who was an Irish biochemist working on the Arden-supported project, Vadim Ivanov, who was working in cardiovascular disease research and his wife, Svetlana Ivanova.
Waheed Rumi, who was doing some really good work in cytotoxic, trying to determine the cytotoxic molity of the vitamin C molecule and some of its derivatives.
Myself.
And it could have been it.
I'm the only one left.
That's right.
Conor McEvally left after the contract supported work expired and that contract had a, you know, a finite start and stop time.
And then Vadim Ivanov and his wife Svetlana decided to return to the Bay Area because they felt more comfortable in the Bay Area.
They really liked California quite a lot.
Vadim and Svetlana had come from the Moscow Cardiological Institute in Russia and found California just paradise compared to what they left in Russia.
And I think they just had a terrific fondness for California.
So they were unwilling to become permanent residents here in Oregon.
And Waheed Rumi left after some time.
We had an interim director at the Institute, Don Reed, who I believe at that time was director of the Environmental Health Science Center as well and a member of the Biochemistry and BioPhysics faculty.
I was going to ask you about his leadership.
Yeah, so he was providing some leadership.
One of the first things that we did together was to hire an office manager.
We hired Barbara McVick, who I believe she was the first employee.
Actually, the first employee was Ober Tias, who was selected by the Oregon State University Foundation to become our fundraiser.
So I worked quite closely with Ober in the very early days in a prize in him of some of our fundraising history, telling him a little bit about some of the contractual relationships we had that generated income from the Institute.
And also some of the charitable foundations and philanthropies who have been very kind to the Institute over the years and talked to him about some of our big donors and be quests and so forth.
So I worked pretty closely. Ober had been coming down to Palo Alto to go through some of our fundraiser files as well to help him identify what was important to bring up to Oregon State.
And of course, one of the most precious resources that was transferred was our donor database because Oregon State University, I think, recognized that absent large government grants, it was going to be tough to keep the Institute going without reliance on the contract we had with Arden and Unilever and also sustained giving by our donors.
So that was very important to keep that safe and to cultivate the donors. And that began even before we moved here.
So what sort of commitment did OSU make to the Institute and I guess five percent?
Well, the commitment was really spelled out in a document that we wrote jointly called a Memorandum of Understanding, which was signed in 1995 by Linus Pong Jr. myself, Paul Risser, who was the incoming president of Oregon State University.
It really spelled out how the Institute's assets, including financial assets, fundraising assets, physical assets, and personnel would be transferred here to the campus of Oregon State University and the Oregon State University Foundation and how the Institute would go through legal dissolution.
And also the expectations for what the University would provide from the Institute in the future, including I think a really key phrase about launching a capital campaign to secure a building from the Institute as soon as that was feasible.
So right from the get go, there was always the promise of a building for the Institute because on any university campus spaces that are premium.
And I'm not sure who had been in the department. So I think Bob chemistry and bio physics may have been in the initial space that the Institute occupied in Wendell-Gur Hall.
But in 1995, after the Memorandum of Understanding had been executed, and renovation of this space on the fifth floor in Wendell-Gur Hall was undertaken, I would come up periodically to work hard with Dick Scanlon and others on the details and logistics of the move from Palo Alto to Corvallis, including an analysis of the laboratory requirements.
So these laboratories were renovated, they were painted, the wood was spiffed up and polished and sanded, and new countertops were installed, air conditioning was installed because these old leaps in the middle of the building didn't have air conditioning, building wide air conditioning.
And there was an area that was the south part of the fifth floor of Wendell-Gur, which was renovated for LPI.
There were still offices and laboratories there for other departments, oceanography and atmospheric sciences to name one, and some other people were still scattered throughout that space.
So it wasn't a contiguous LPI space from the west end around to the east end, but it was certainly satisfactory for the Institute's initial efforts here at Oregon State.
So the furniture, the laboratory equipment, centrifuges, laboratory supplies, chemicals, paper, journals, a lot of the material from Pauling's office in Palo Alto.
It was all transferred up, moved up in August of, excuse me, July of 1996.
And that was a very, very difficult process because we had, we managed to move ourselves, we had professional movers of course, we hired to make this move, but we had to make lots of decisions in Palo Alto, but what should be moved and what shouldn't be moved and what could be recycled and what could be thrown away and so on and so forth.
So we filled up two dumpsters a week for well over a month with just junk that we had no use for in the future.
And then of course everything was packed securely and brought up here at Oregon State University.
And a lot of the journals and laboratory equipment that wasn't in use immediately was stored in the sixth floor of Wendell-Gur and with some storage on the fifth floor as well.
And then over time, especially after Bult's fry was recruited as the director of the Linus-Pawing Institute in here at Oregon State.
And following that, because I think I mentioned once before that when the candidates for director that in dad position came to interview on campus, I think they all asked the University Administration the same question, which is what are you going to do to provide for growth for the Institute?
How will the Institute grow? And I think the University to its credit responded satisfactorily to those questions by offering to set up a couple of faculty lines and start up packages in order to recruit new faculty.
So that was also something that I think it was an incentive in recruiting a good director that we would have the ability to grow the Institute built in to the initial program.
So as Wendell-Bult's fry assumed that position and we set about recruiting new faculty, the material that had been stored in the fifth floor had to be moved.
And at that time, a lot of the filing cabinets that stored Polling's files and manuscripts and so forth were moved over here to special collections.
And a lot of the other stuff that we perceive no need to keep old journals, for instance, that the library couldn't use and we really had no need for or storage capacity, physically and when it were recycled.
So the University did commit to some ongoing funding then it wasn't just an issue of providing space and saying that we'll have a foundation represents that.
I hope you raise money for all of through all of you.
Some ongoing funding as well.
Well, in the memorandum of understanding that ongoing funding to provide start-up packages and salary lines for additional faculty, that was not part of the memorandum of understanding.
That was something that developed as a result of feedback from interviews for the director among the director candidates.
And to be honest with you, because I had not had professional experience within a university environment nor had Linus, Paul and Junior, nor had the other members of our Board of Trustees with the exception of a couple, it wasn't something that we anticipated.
So had we anticipated that we really needed to secure a mechanism at that time to grow the institute, we probably would have incorporated that in the memorandum of understanding.
But I think that was an issue that escaped the analysis at that time.
It was only later that that was really addressed.
But the idea for a building from the institute was there right from the beginning, because we recognized that the renovated part of Wendellgar was not going to be sufficient.
Should the institute be successful, that wasn't going to be big enough to hold the institute and we thought that having our own building would be really a fending tribute to Linus, Paul.
And I think John Byrne and people at Oregon State University agreed that that was important.
And it sounds like President Byrne was crucial to this process happening in the first place within the August and the around and working with his perspective as role was.
Well Paul Risser didn't have much to do with it mechanistically, because he signed the memorandum of understanding, because by the time that document was generated, John Byrne was leaving his president.
So Paul Risser was the incoming president. And I think there were a lot of press releases that about that time as well.
So Paul Risser had to respond as the new face of Oregon State University about this move of the Linus, playing the institute and so forth.
But his scientific training, I believe, was as a botanist.
So he probably had less appreciation for Pauling scientific work than maybe people in the other biological sciences or in the physical sciences like physics and chemistry.
He certainly was aware of Linus Pauling, but I think this was basically John Byrne's baby and Dick Scanlon at that time assumed a really pivotal role, a very important role in helping the institute to integrate into Oregon State University.
So Paul Risser was certainly aware of everything and very supportive of everything, but did not play a really pivotal role early on.
It was really Dick Scanlon and it was working very hard in this area.
What were your initial impressions of the university and the analysis?
Well, I'll be frank, my initial impressions were not great.
I had spent my life in the East Coast near Boston and at Stanford near San Francisco, which was a hive of activity, intellectual, cultural activity, academic activity, Silicon Valley here burgeoned during my time there.
So it was a very dynamic and kind of thrilling and overstimulating type of environment that I'd grown to love.
So coming up here to Corvallis, Corvallis struck me as a very sleepy tab in those days.
Didn't seem to have a big bookstore in town. Didn't seem to have many movie theaters.
Didn't seem to have a lot of good restaurants.
And to be honest, it surprised me because here's a college town with tens of thousands of students and a lot of faculty who are very bright and energetic.
And I was surprised that that kind of energy and intellectual diamondism, which I'm sure existed here on campus, didn't translate into more that I could perceive in town.
So nevertheless, I felt that this was the best option for the institute and I felt compelled from a professional standpoint to work very hard to ensure that the institute was a success.
Because like Linus Paul in junior, we didn't really want to see this fail and see what could become a really successful working tribute to Linus Paul and turn it into a disaster.
So I felt personally and professionally committed to making this work and I realized that it was probably imperative for me to become part of this process in moving from California to Oregon, at least initially, to get the institute up and running and make sure that everything was was happening appropriately and that we didn't really lose sight of the reason that the institute existed in the first place, namely the study of orthomolecular medicine.
I was a little surprised at kind of the parochial and kind of provincial attitude of some of the faculty here at Oregon State, nutrition and so forth seemed to be a little old-fashioned to me.
But I thought the institute would probably settle in and do quite well and there were a number of faculty who were extraordinarily bright and excited about the institute being here and they were the ones that we were going to be working with so I felt that I felt very good about that.
But I was concerned really about my own personal satisfaction here in Corvallis. I mean I know that the ocean is an hour and a half away and the mountains are an hour and a half away and Portland is an hour away.
But everything's at least an hour away and in Palo Alto I was very right in the midst of things. San Francisco is a short train ride, half hour by car at that.
So I was concerned about that but Corvallis has changed quite a lot over the years as well.
Did you mention Big Stanley? Big Stanley was an important early ally as well. Was it important in terms of getting things to serve integrated?
I think George Bailey was very important as well. He was an environmental and molecular tax college and director of the Marine Freshwater Biomedical Sciences Center at the time using trout as a model to study Carson agenesis.
I think that's been part of this committee that had been set up by Dick Skinner and John Burns to sort of investigate the association of the institute with OSU.
Also Chris Matthews who is the chairman of the department about chemistry and biophysics. I think played a very important role.
Part of the reason these people were important was that new faculty coming into the institute which was essential.
We're going to have their academic homes in different departments across campus and maybe even in different colleges across campus.
So it was very important for the institute to be well integrated and be close to these departmental chairs and deans as well.
I think John Leong played a very important role early on and Tim White I think was involved as well.
I can't remember all the people who constituted the search committee for the director but a number of those people were also on the search committee.
We took that job extremely seriously and reviewed numerous applications and whittled the field down to a number of really outstanding candidates and then set about presenting each member of the search committee presented two candidates.
The choice was overwhelming for Balstri which was terrific.
Also Phil Wanger who was I believe an environmental molecular toxicology working on Selenium at that time was also someone who was closely associated with the institute.
The higher Balstri strikes me in the rural watershift moment.
It really was.
He was a hiring Balstri who was working of course on vitamin C was very strategic.
He's a terrific scientist. He had terrific recommendations from Bruce Aims the National Academy of Science member and winner of the award that Paul and got from Gerald Ford.
National mental science winner as well.
Bruce Aims recommended him extremely strongly and Balstri had had we knew him as well or at least I had known him for a few years since his parents to give a seminar at the Institute back in California.
He had after leaving Bruce Aims lab as a postdoc at Berkeley he'd gone to Harvard, had a position there and was currently at Boston University School of Medicine to work on vitamin C and atherosclerosis.
So we felt that it would be terrific for the institute to get him because we would ensure central importance of orthomoluculent medicine.
And coincidentally one of Paul's favorite molecules vitamin C would have a very prominent place in the institute's research and Balstri would be a really terrific director.
And then with the faculty lines and startup packages created by OSU, the research office, I think that really was an exciting time and that really showed that we now had a mechanism for moving forward.
We weren't going to be completely dependent on fundraising from our donors in order to make the institute a success.
Now we're going to be able to bring in high caliber faculty because of these faculty lines.
And when those people were recruited things really started to progress pretty dramatically.
So a year later you hired Tori Hagen, Merrick Trayvert and Rod Dashwood.
That's right. So the backbone research back on the green institute all three are endowed with now.
That's right. That's right. That was very, those were all very good decisions.
Tori now is director of our Healthy Aging Program. Rod Dashwood is director of the Cancer Came-up Protection Program.
Rod had been here previously to work with George Bailey many many years ago and is one of the leading researchers in the field.
Researchers in phytochemicals and cancer in the world. So that was a very important part of our research program.
And Merrick Trayvert coming up from UC Berkeley from Lester Packers Lab, one of the world's authorities on vitamin E.
So we thought that the combination of Tori Hagen working on agi-central micronutrients, rod working in phytochemical protection against Carson agenesis
and merrett working in molecular mechanisms of vitamin E, another very important physiologically antioxidant.
And then in Balte's Fry working on vitamin C would really constitute a great attack in some of these problems that had interested in his point.
Did it save this in the fall of this sentence or the essential for you to do that at the time?
I think it's probably safe to say that. I think Balte's impressed all of them. Of course Merrett Trayvert new Balte's already from their prior association at UC Berkeley.
But I think his acumen and abilities and energy and reputation as a scientist who are really critical in attracting these other candidates who were hired.
And Merrett, these foreign peoples ability to successfully attract that energy that I'm sure was.
That's right. That's right. It's always been a consideration, a major consideration for becoming a principal investigator in the institute and being selected from the enormously large pool of qualified candidates.
The ability to support a research program through NIH or NCI funding or independent funding is can't be understated.
And it's absolutely critical to be considered for a position like that. And to achieve success in that kind of funding on a regular basis, I think it speaks very well with a caliber of any candidate who's selected for that position.
David Williams was very extraordinary.
David Williams was doing very good work here in environmental and molecular toxicology and also had assumed directorship of the Marine Fresh Water Biomedical Sciences Center.
So he also was very interested in phytochemical protection against Carson and Genesis which fit right into the institute's mission. And he's been a principal investigator all this time as well.
He was not recruited extremely. He was at OSU. George Bailey of course continued to remain as a professor at OSU just retired a few years ago.
And I think we've been very fortunate that none of the faculty we've recruited has left for a better job than he plays out.
So I think it shows that the institute has become a collegial and productive home for people where they feel good about their ability to carry out their research programs and like their colleagues.
At some point the institute changed its name from the one who's calling it to the science medicine to just one of the point institute and where it could come at the reason why.
Yeah well that's kind of the two organizations overlapped. So the institute as a 501 C3 incorporated in the state of California was known from 1973 or 4 on as the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
The institute as it exists here at Oregon State University has always been known as the Linus Pauling Institute and is was independent from the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
When the institute moved here we transferred our as I said our financial assets physical assets and some personnel to establish the Linus Pauling Institute at Oregon State University.
But the Shell organization continued to be viable in the state of California for actually quite a few years after that.
And there were a number of reasons for that. One reason was we wanted to continue to be the recipient of be quests that names specifically the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
And there were a couple of be quests in the offing in which the executors and attorneys handling the estate weren't sure that they could recognize Oregon State University of the Oregon State University Foundation as the successor to the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
So we thought rather than imperil any of these large be quests in the world there were several that were quite large that it would just be best to continue that Shell organization that could be the recipient of some of these funds and be quests.
There are also legal issues that needed to be tied up with litigation with Rex E. Jerroloa about wrongful termination that needed to be resolved.
There was litigation continuing in litigation with the TSRAF that needed to be resolved.
And there were mainly financial and legal issues that were still dangling.
I didn't know that about Jerroloa.
Yeah, he, everybody in California as I might have mentioned was at will that was employment status.
And it's very popular employment status in the state of California where you don't offer people contracts.
It would have been nice to offer people long term contracts but it really was not economically feasible to do that or prudent because the institute had no reliably safe source of chronic funding.
We didn't have an endowment and as you know as you were well aware the income was up and down over the years.
So in California there's what's known as at will employment which means that you can be fired virtually anytime for no cause or you could leave at any time with no notice.
But it mainly benefits the employer, not the employee.
And I feel terrible about continuing that policy but it really there was really no way to move to any other kind of policy at that time in Palo Alto.
And of course the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine really had no absolute influence on which employees from that organization would be offered jobs by Oregon State University.
So the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine was not making job offers to its own employees to come to Corvallis to take a position.
Oregon State University was making those offers.
So when it became clear which staff members in Palo Alto would be offered jobs and which weren't offered jobs.
Then the people who were not going to be offered jobs some retired, some had made a decision, some resigned made a decision that they didn't want to go to Oregon anyway.
And some were laid off and Rex seat Jerawalla in turn sued the Institute for wrongful termination.
And that was another one of these outstanding, excuse me, litigations that was a reason why the Institute could not go out of business right away.
So there was a period of overlap. There was the Linus Pong Institute here at Oregon State University and there was a continuing shell organization in California, the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine.
Another reason was that we had entered into a contract with Arden and Unilever and that contract with the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine.
So there were lots of complicated legal and financial issues that all of us agreed seem to be resolved by just keeping the Institute a shell organization until all these loose ends could be tied up.
And then that finally was achieved about 2005.
2003-2005, I can't remember the exact year but that's finally when the Institute went through legal dissolution and transferred remaining assets to Oregon State University Foundation.
So I served kind of two roles. I served continuing to serve as the chief executive officer of LPSM and then also the administrative officer for LPI here at Oregon State University.
In 2000, one of your more interesting and successful sort of public outreach efforts for the Microweague Treatment Information Center came online.
I wanted to talk about that a little bit. One thing that's interesting and looking at it is that by that point the Institute is definitely back the way from the negatives claims about LI-18.
So the University is getting more and a little bit more into the work that we're talking about and the Institute is active.
Now where did you talk about the combination behind that?
Sure. Well there's never been a litmus test for employment at the Linus Pong Institute even in California.
And people have different behavior as far as supplementation goes.
People in California at the Institute who took large doses of vitamin C and vitamin E and multivitamins, there were people who didn't take supplemental vitamins.
So it's never been a litmus test and nobody has ever been forced to tow the party line about vitamin supplements.
Everybody's free to make up their own mind about what to do and what to recommend and so forth.
I think the scientists associated with the Linus Pong Institute that came on board here in Oregon all had without fail, tremendous respect for Linus Pong.
But probably as good scientists were a little skeptical of the enormous mega doses that Pong advocated.
Therefore weren't comfortable in recommending these kinds of doses themselves because they either hadn't done the research to convince them that the magnitude of these doses was warranted in each and every case.
That's my guess is they just weren't familiar with a lot of Pong's arguments about this.
So the micronutrient information center came about in the year 2000.
I think partly as a result of conversations at early retreats and also feedback from the scientific advisory board about the Institute being a resource for peer reviewed scientifically accurate and updated information on the role of micronutrients, including vitamins and minerals and phytochemicals and dietary constituents.
In preventing disease, treating disease went applicable and also in obtaining optimum health.
We had an idea somewhat similar to this on a more limited scale back in California where we had talked about becoming a resource for a worldwide resource for vitamin C information specifically because we had some expertise in vitamin C obviously through Linus Pong and other staff members.
We had talked about that if there was some way to become a resource for that kind of information.
And again this was before the internet had really taken off so it would have required hiring people with more knowledge about nutrition and molecular biology and the intersection between nutrition and molecular biology and medicine.
We just didn't have the funds to do that at that time and it was also probably not prudent because there was a lot of uncertainty about the future of the Institute.
So it would have been foolhardy to set up a new program only to lose it with the move of the Institute to a new location or the liquidation of the Institute or something like that.
So we never acted on that dream at that time but then this kind of resurfaced in a broader sense before the year 2000 and the idea then of course the internet had really taken off to make this an electronic, electronically accessible database.
And we started thinking about who would be appropriate to set up and manage such a database and we felt somebody with a PhD in nutrition or molecular biology related to nutrition and somebody with some computer skills would be required to do this.
So at that time Jane Higden had just gotten a PhD in nutrition from Oregon State University and was not interested in pursuing a career in experimental science, wasn't really interested in securing a tenure track position in academia but was interested in staying in the scientific realm.
She applied for that position and she was perfectly suited for it. She had had experience as a nurse in New York City, I think she got a nursing degree from Pace University and had gotten an undergraduate degree in biology from Stanford.
So she was quite smart and had great experience and was willing to take on this task of setting up our Microngeg Information Center.
And we also hired somebody to work with her who could do the initial computer work and software that was required to get this up and running.
Excuse me, so the two of them collaborated on this and over the years it's developed into quite an astonishing resource and to the extent that
when we thought about updating Pauline's book Had a Live Longer and Feel Better and this is something that Pauline himself had pursued back in the 80s and he'd signed a contract with Brian Lieberwitz as a matter of fact to work on an update of how to live longer and feel better.
But I think they had a disagreement about the strategy there and the scope of the work and that really came to not.
But Linus Point Jr., and I were very interested in getting a new addition of how to live longer and feel better, published.
And we talked to a number of people that we thought would be good candidates including Gladys Block.
We wanted somebody who was sympathetic to Pauline's ideas and orthomolechin and medicine but also extremely knowledgeable and kept up with the literature and so forth.
We wanted to find someone to do that who already has a productive research career is really difficult and we weren't able to locate anyone to carry out that work.
And then with the advent of my Knuchin Information Center, it occurred to me that that was really an electronic update of Pauline's book because now we were continuing to stay abreast of all the research information in orthomolechin and medicine.
Instead of compiling it into a book, it was online.
So we decided when the prospect of publishing an anniversary edition of how to live longer and feel better came up and I approached Oregon State University Press about that.
We decided to keep the book intact, add back some illustrations and other work that had been deleted because when the book went from trade paper back sides on nice paper to mass market paper back sides on coarse paper, some of the resolution of the type was lost and some of the illustrations just weren't appropriate.
So they were deleted from that mass market paper back edition.
We wanted to bring those back and decided that the best way of doing this new edition of the book, which would be the 20th anniversary edition, would be to have a new forward written and afterward kind of put the working context with on the basis of new research that had been done since the book was first published in 1986.
And also makes some judicious annotations where people at Pauline refers to, for instance, in the present tense who have died, maybe indicate that the people have died or if the RDA has changed, maybe indicate why the RDA has changed or the UL and things like that.
So we really limited to tinkering with the text to annotations and then providing some more text at the beginning and end of the book.
And then directing people in the afterward to visit the Micronutrient Information Center because that really provides an update of how to live longer and feel better.
And over the years, as the number of chapters grew in that Micronutrient Information Center and it became and was always widely accessible through search engines, it's become enormously popular.
So recently it's been getting on the order of 20 to 25 million hits per year. And most of those, of course, are not local.
They're all over the country, all over the world. And it's been a terrific resource for people to use in consulting with their physicians about health problems or to find out more about the biochemical or physiological action of some of these important Micronutrients.
The emphasis in the Micronutrient Information Center has always been on human health. So we will revert to discussing cell culture or animal studies when there doesn't seem to be much human data available.
But the focus is really on humans because humans are the ones that are reading this, the ones that are interested in applying this information to their own health. And that's been the focus.
And the information that has been written by Jane Higden and she was succeeded by Dr. Victoria Drake. And now we have another person working with Victoria Drake on the Micronutrient Information Center on John A. Angelo.
All the articles that they write are sent out to meeting experts in the field for peer review. And then they're periodically updated as well to take into account new information, new studies that might cause the end of the day.
So we have to pause the institute to modify its recommendations. So the end of each of these chapters ends with a line of applying recommendation. And in many cases it's very similar to or the same as the DRIs that the Food Nutrition Board publishes.
In some cases it's different. And in the case of Vitamin C for instance it's different. We don't recommend the enormous quantities that line is applying recommended in part because pharmacokinetic studies and molecular studies
have revealed that the amount of Vitamin C absorbed from the gut into the bloodstream is limited by the sodium Vitamin C transporters which are relatively newly discovered.
They hadn't been discovered by the time Pauline died. But they are known now. And it explains why only a fraction of a very small dose of Vitamin C gets from the gut into the bloodstream.
It's limited. It's controlled by these Vitamin C transporters. So it just doesn't diffuse against a gradient or something. It really is limited.
So practically speaking and biochemically it doesn't make sense to take a huge dose of Vitamin C because only a small fraction of that will be absorbed.
So we decided on the basis of meta-analyses, on the basis of biochemical epidemiological studies, that it's important to keep blood levels of Vitamin C very high that produce not really saturation but very high concentrations in circulating cells in the blood and also cells in different tissues because Vitamin C is very important and non-toxic.
So we recommend now to get at least 400 milligrams a day. So by saying at least 400 milligrams a day, we recognize that it's important to get much more than what the RDA is for instance.
And we also recognize implicitly the safety of high dose Vitamin C. So we don't specifically recommend many grams a day but we recognize also that high dose Vitamin C is very safe.
As a matter of fact the UL, which is the upper tolerable, upper level of intake for Vitamin C, was established in 2000 and 2000 milligrams per day based solely on the transient laxative effect of higher doses in some people.
Which is really not a serious side effect. It's not really pathological or toxic.
And is the argument in favor of intravenous Vitamin C in the possible therapeutic procedure that does that still have any question?
Well actually that's been greatly reinvigorated by some of these pharmacokinetic studies.
After the Mayo Clinic studies as we discussed, there was kind of a dismissal of Vitamin C, the utility of Vitamin C as a therapeutic agent in cancer and a lot of oncologists and physicians became very uninterested in Vitamin C.
This pedestrian molecule, it's already been studied by the Mayo Clinic, it's failed so therefore it's time to move on.
However, pharmacokinetic studies that really demonstrated very clearly in these transport studies in molecular biology.
Have something I throw?
Showed that when you give Vitamin C intravenously you get much higher concentrations in the blood than you do when you take it orally.
In depending upon the dose given intravenously you can end up with millimolar concentrations in the blood.
When you take Vitamin C orally it's tough to get above about 200 micromole per liter in the blood concentration.
So millimolar you're talking about 70 or 100 times greater concentration of Vitamin C when given intravenously.
That led people conducting these pharmacokinetic studies to think more carefully about why camera work with Pauling was so successful in Scotland and why the Mayo Clinic's work in Minnesota failed.
It's pretty clear that these high levels of Vitamin C exhibit cytotoxicity, selective cytotoxicity against tumor cells.
This has been shown in cell culture experiments for many many many years.
Even in the early 1980s Pauling himself published with Japanese colleagues a paper showing that Vitamin C had cytotoxicity against tumor cells in culture and that this was completely nullified by the addition of catalysts to the culture medium.
And catalysts of course quenches hydrogen peroxide so they surmise that the cytotoxicity was due to Vitamin C acting as a prooxenant and generating hydrogen peroxide which was then killing tumor cells.
So this very mechanism was then rediscovered many years later and shown to occur when you get these pharmacological concentrations of Vitamin C in the blood when given intravenously.
It starts generating hydrogen peroxide which attacks tumor cells and it seems to be very selective either normal cells are protected by endogenous antioxidants or some other protected mechanism as it play.
And that led to renewed interest in the prospect of using high dose IV Vitamin C as a junk of therapy and cancer and there have been many many anecdotal studies published, case histories published and a couple of phase one clinical trials published as well.
So I think there's quite a lot of interest now but there are also quite a lot of issues that need to be much more fully characterized.
For instance which types of human cancer are most sensitive to these high concentrations of Vitamin C which patients are the best candidates for high dose Vitamin C at what stage of cancer can Vitamin C be given with chemotherapy drugs in a synergistic manner.
Would Vitamin C negate the effect of some types of chemotherapy drugs should it be used in connection with radiotherapy and what would be the optimum protocol for administration of Vitamin C.
For instance Cameron with his terminally old patient population these people were hospitalized waiting to die so he could give continuous slow drip intravenous Vitamin C, high dose Vitamin C.
Hour after hour day after day. So retrospectively you're thinking about this and thinking that hydrogen peroxide must have been rather continuously generated and rather continuously attacking these tumor cells in vivo.
For many patients now who get high dose IV Vitamin C it's given in a periodic fashion two or three times a week very high doses.
So hydrogen peroxide is being generated transiently and then after four to six hours the level of Vitamin C in the blood is right back at baseline no more hydrogen peroxide generation presumably.
So those kinds of issues whether it's okay to have periodic generation of hydrogen peroxide through intermittent IV Vitamin C use or whether this continuous generation of hydrogen peroxide is more effective.
All these issues are very nuanced and difficult and I think have to be really thoroughly characterized before we'll really understand the merits of Vitamin C against cancer.
But there are people that are actively working in that area and they recognize all these issues.
In 2001 it begins to two house fits first diet and not coming to health conference and that also came with the first LPI advice for health research which is a $50,000 prize pretty remarkable time around for an organization that is two doing on the treatment going out of business in 15 years before.
It's a really amazing turnaround and part of that has to do with I think Rick Hicks cultivation of donors over the years by always putting information about be quests and playing gifts in the periodic newsletter that went out to our constituents.
So we're aware from the mid 70s on and named the institute and their wills and those be quests that came in very irregularly and unpredictably to the institute allowed us to do really wonderful things including endowing new faculty positions within the institute convening things like the diet not to them health conference and giving that prize for health research.
And also the fact that the cost of doing business here at Oregon State was much less because we weren't having to pay rent any longer.
We weren't having to pay people to participate in a large fundraising program or pay a controller, bookkeeper and so forth.
So a lot of the activities that had to be supported as an independent organization did not have to be supported in this context of Oregon State University.
So costs were down and therefore the be quests and the money that was coming in could be could be applied towards growth of the institute instead of just merely sustaining the institute.
Also in 2001 Jill Beckman arrived at the institute and talked a little bit about the background behind that and the fact that he has worked on ALS in the sort of open up a different angle of research for the institute.
That's right there always been interest of course in neurodegenerative diseases at the institute and we were looking for a candidate who could open up that new area of research and Jill Beckman was one who applied and he'd done some really outstanding work on molecular work on ALS in Birmingham, Alabama at the University of Alabama.
Showing that peroxin nitrite is a very interesting destructive molecule that is generated through the evolution of nitric oxide in the body, very damaging molecule.
So his work really appealed to us reactive nitrogen species was kind of a new avenue of research reactive oxygen species work of course have been undertaken by many people all around the world for many years including some at LPI but reactive nitrogen species was kind of a new facet of this that would be very interesting pursue.
He was given the Aether Helen Pauline in dad position because we thought it would be nice to honor Linus Pauline's wife with the second in dad position and at that time we had the money thanks to bequeous in order to do that.
And also some of the money that came into the institute at that time was not just from bequeous but also from legal actions as an example when the insurance companies refused to reimbursus for legal expenses during the Rath litigation.
I decided to sue the insurance companies because they weren't honoring our claims and they made up reasons why they couldn't honor the claims but nevertheless commercial liability and directors and officers insurance I thought would apply and I was shocked that they refused to honor these claims so we decided to sue them.
And that was settled before going to trial and that resulted in quite a large amount of money coming to the institute as well so we had money coming in from a number of different avenues that allowed us to adopt these positions.
We talked about the principal investigators and balls and when it is any of the folks that have been made here in the last 10 years or so to have tried in the past institute.
Well I think clearly the people who were operating the research office were have been very important because balls probably reports to the head of the research office and the money that are available through returned overhead and through the research office have been very important to the institute over the years.
The deans and departmental chairs have also been extraordinarily important because when candidates are being interviewed and reviewed for a faculty position within the institute as a principal investigator at the institute they have to have an academic home as well which means that the chairperson of the appropriate academic unit and his or her colleagues and faculty members have to vote on whether or not this candidate will fit into their department.
So it is a very convoluted and entwined process of selecting someone for the institute and for an academic department.
So all the departmental heads have been quite important as well.
That was your job change over time.
Well my job has changed in so far as I obviously am no longer the chief executive officer of the Linus Plungus to the science and medicine which was kind of a parallel track for me and once that was finally legally dissolved and I didn't have to think about that any longer and basically could focus on my responsibilities as administrative officer for the institute.
And from the when we first moved here I took over editor ship of the newsletter because we recognize that the newsletter continued to be an important educational tool and fundraising tool from the institute and I thought I could do it and Don read thought I could do it so I just started to do that unilaterally.
And that's been a lot of fun we have historically given out pilot project grants to fund initial research by people doing work related to the institute of the mission in order to allow them to obtain enough data to apply for larger more sustaining grants from say NCI or NIH.
And the work that they've done has always been reported in the newsletter so talking to those people getting asking them for articles for the newsletter editing those articles trying to translate that information from very technical language to language that's a little more friendly to the casual reader has been a lot of my responsibility.
And then of course pursuing this option of a new building for the institute has been something that both Ryan I've been working on right from the beginning very diligently and then when the funding finally came together for that even before the funding came together we spend quite a lot of time talking to architects and visiting buildings and so forth trying to get a clearer idea of what it was we wanted.
And also to provide us with material that could be shown to prospective donors so we wanted to have a good idea of what the institute could look like with the new building could look like and have something that we could show to people a visual representation of this model or something like that so he and I worked very closely on on all that work and I became a member of the steering committee for the Linus Pong Science Center.
So I'd say for the last couple years two or three years I've been working very intensively with user groups trying to identify issues that needed to be incorporated into the design and given to the architects to design our building.
And also there's always been a bit of a fundraising component to my position as well because I have such a long history with the institute and I know about a lot of our past activities and I knew Linus Pong pretty well.
I'm often asked by our fundraiser or other groups, so Rudry Club, Lyons Club, different groups here at Oregon State University and elsewhere to give talks on Pong and the orthomolecular medicine or to provide.
Overviews of the research that's going on at the institute now and I rather often in two or three times a year travel to scientific or medical conferences to make presentations on Pong and orthomolecular medicine and to give those kinds of updates.
My last set of questions is about the building and it opened this last September more or less and you were obviously involved in that process from the beginning.
Well it's just such a terrific change from the institute.
I went to one of her as I said was completely satisfactory in the early days for the institute but as the institute grew we became very fragmented because we had faculty in different buildings all over campus and it became less and less likely to interact with fellow faculty who were part of the institute.
Of course I think that decreases the collegiality and also diminishes the prospect for good meaningful scientific interactions on a frequent basis that could generate new ideas and make progress in research projects.
So the new building has allowed almost all the institute principal investigators to be housed together now. Joe Beckman is still in ALS but it's just a stone's throw from the Linus Pong Science Center which is next to Nash which is the building that sits between ALS and the Linus Pong Science Center.
So he's still physically very close to the institute although not part of the building itself. And being in a very spacious well lit modern building with open lab space and modular space that's quite flexible is just such a such a wonderful inspiration for everyone.
And the interaction with your colleagues now is dramatically increased as well because all the offices are aligned along the north wall on the third floor and the fourth floor.
And there's an open atrium kind of a cathedral-esque environment between the third and fourth floor. A staircase in the middle there allows people to get from one floor to the other.
So there's just this feeling of openness and integration that is really wonderful.
Now that you've achieved this milestone in this building what it now is the next set of priorities for us to promise and realize that.
Well the next set of priorities I think are to expand and develop our Micronutrient Information Center and also work on a new program in our outreach which is called the Healthy Youth Program which is trying to introduce the concepts of good nutrition and lifestyle among elementary school children and middle school children.
So that kids can get good ideas about how to stay healthy when they're young in terms of exercise and eating well.
And also we still have the ability to recruit more faculty for our Healthy Aging Program.
Once we recruit more faculty for our Healthy Aging Program I think we'll be saturated with respect to four principal investigators per area having labs in the Linus Pong Institute.
Well that's the end of my questions are there any things that you didn't cover that come to mine off hand that we should talk about as far as it is to other areas you were prepared for that?
It's going to be a discussion.
Probably but I can't think of anything off hand so let me think about that.
Thank you.